Most people probably wouldn't consider butter
a flammable substance, and it's not really.
But it could be. In this project, we're making
emergency candles that will burn for hours,
from a piece of toilet paper, and a stick
of butter.
For this project I got into my wife's baking
supplies and found this 4oz stick of butter.
The butter can be placed on top of a few squares
of toilet paper and now it's ready to cut
in half. You can use a sharp knife to cut
cleanly through the paper, and holding it
with the folds at the top will help prevent
the paper from binding and ripping as you
push down through the block. Alright, we've
got our two halves, now let's make the wick.
Take one square of toilet paper and some scissors,
and cut it into quarters so you end up with
a little square like this. Now this can be
folded down diagonally and twisted tightly
to give it support. I've folded this one at
the bottom for two reasons, height and convenience.
When it gets placed into the butter, there
will only be 1/4" of the wick sticking up
at the top and that's about all we want. Using
something like a toothpick or a skewer, poke
a hole in the center of the butter all the
way to the bottom. Now set your wick over
the hole, and use the skewer to push it down
into place. A little twist should release
it, and it looks like it's set. Now, we'll
need to add a little starter fuel to the wick,
and that's done by rubbing it around in the
butter until it's got a nice coating. At this
point your candle is ready to go. When you
strike your match, hold it near the base of
the wick so that it helps heat the butter.
If your butter was frozen like mine, it might
take a few seconds before the flame is fully
self sustaining. But there it is, a dairy
powered candle. Not only is this butter candle
easy to make, but each half will burn for
about 4 hours. As the butter gets melted,
the liquid is wicked and released as a vapor
into the flame, and it's the vapor that you
see burning. Dropping your candle into a glass
will help keep the flame steady, as well as
set a nice ambience for the room. It doesn't
get much simpler than this, but if you decide
you need a firmer wick, try straightening
a paperclip and wrapping your wicking paper
around that for support. This will prevent
your wick from falling over when the fuel
burns down and liquifies. Well there's how
to make a simple emergency candle using some
toilet paper and a bit of butter. If you like
this project, perhaps you'll like some of
my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com